all right
you're doing amazing sweetie
we pull a line yes we pull a lot
and then a move
let's go this should be interesting
you're trying to keep your cool but
about to explode give me what i'm
needing
depressed i'm the furthest thing from
depressed i mean look at what i've
accomplished do you see him do you think
a depressed person could have made this
you're on a soap opera need some music
for this one violin
attention
[ __ ] and losers
i have an announcement
this meeting is over because it has come
to my attention that every one of you
sucks ass
the mood is if i had a few cocktails i
have nuts and shellfish allergies are
either of those in the honey walnut
shrimp no is that your american accent
that was good
asmr was whispering
sometimes
i'm afraid to hold a new baby
what if i lose control of my arms for a
second
and throw it at the ceiling fan
so you just received your fourth parking
ticket in one week so you're frustrated
ah live from new york it's saturday
night live here it is there it is you
just ate a lemon
boy
have you lost your mind
because
you just found out an unknown relative
left you 10 million dollars
i will rob you of your sanity and loving
nurse you back to health
only to destroy you again what as if a
significant other is breaking up with
you
cam
there are people dying
and seeing and seeing thank you the mood
is
you're trying to keep your cool
if you're about to explode i'm a goddess
i am a glorious female warrior
as if you're flirting oh i love it
because i
turned into a wolf and ate him
so all of his are sexy as if you're a
sports announcer be cool
don't be like uncle
i'm a two-year-old you want your mind
okay yeah you keep doing it
because i turned into a wolf and ate him
thank you so i have something just not
me sitting up here in lemons
as if a significant other is breaking up
sometimes i'm afraid to hold a new baby
what if i get scared and throw it into a
ceiling fan
oh wow you just went in like you
auditioning for like you know a new show
as if in a classical musical you have to
sing it
the worst rights can't live without them
cause they won't move in with you
[Music]
you